John Blackstone is near the scene just
south of the famous Las Vegas strip John
good morning good morning well police
say they found in the Mandalay Bay Hotel
back here that room was filled with
weapons as many as ten weapons in the
room that this gunman was using to shoot
down into the crowd that was gathered
for this concert on the other side of
the Las Vegas Strip now cell phone video
is helping investigators put together
exactly what happened many of the people
gathered there say was the scariest time
of their life initially many thought the
pops they heard were fireworks
associated with the show but soon it
became obvious that this was an attack
what sounded like automatic gunfire rang
out late Sunday night
the bullets spraying into a crowd of
roughly 22,000 concert goers on the Las
Vegas Strip these videos captured the
chaos unfolding on the ground there was
confusion about where the bullets were
coming from or even if they were bullets
[Applause]
some were frozen in panic others fled
for their lives and all of a sudden we
heard pop pop pop up countless at times
and we all thought it was firecrackers
the medic kept on going and then he
cried for a bit then he fired another 15
20 rounds and that's what we realized it
was a fully automatic
police say the gunshots came from above
there was an a computer that was firing
rounds from the 32nd floor we are still
going through the search warrant
actively at this time but it's an excess
of 10 rifles the suspect is now dead and
authorities are still trying to piece
together the scope of the carnage right
now we need your truck we just need to
get people over to the hospital okay the
injured were scattered all along the Las
Vegas Strip
bystanders tried to get those hit by
gunfire to the hospital any way they
could some were falling and some were
screaming and yelling and running so
everyone was just like literally laying
on top of each other trying to get out
of the way it was a terrible night here
in Las Vegas and as the Sun comes up
here this morning we're bracing for even
worse with more than 400 people in the
hospital many of them in critical
condition the sheriff has warned that
the death toll could well rise above 50
Jeff